la espera de los resultados debido a que
las elecciones en Estados Unidos no son
organizadas por una autoridad central
sino que se rigen por la legislación de
cada estado los espera un anuncio
general de los resultados una vez
cerrada las urnas cada estado decide las
reglas de juego para que sus ciudadano
se ejerzan su derecho al voto Algunos
permiten que las votaciones inicien
semanas antes pero otros no dejan que
esto ocurra sino hasta el mismo día de
las elecciones causando grandes retrasos
en los conteos finales
más de 43 millones de estadounidenses
votaron anticipadamente por correo o en
persona siendo California Texas y
Florida los más anticipados
usualmente los demócratas prefieren
votar por correo mientras que los
republicanos optan por la presencialidad
así los reportes de los resultados se
conocerán en distintos momentos durante
la noche del 8 de noviembre y en los
días posteriores
para las elecciones de medio término de
2018 los resultados parciales que
dejaron como ganador al partido
demócrata se conocieron Un día después
para obtener la victoria se necesita una
mayoría simple el partido que logre
superar 50 votos sobre 100 gana si no se
alcanza este número se debe citar a una
segunda vuelta el próximo 6 de diciembre
estas elecciones renovarán la cámara de
representantes un tercio del senado y 36
gobernaciones y son cruciales para saber
el rumbo que tomará la gestión del
presidente Joe biden hasta el final de
su mandato y la fuerza de Donald Trump
de Cara a su posible candidatura
presidencial para los comicios del 2024